bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'apple et du futur iphone est ceux de
[Musique]
alors ça fait déjà un petit moment que
la rumeur circule apple pourrait sortir
en 2018 une nouvelle version de son
iphone est ce c'est un téléphone qui est
déjà présent depuis quelques années avec
un look un peu anciens anciens parce que
c'est vrai qu'apple un peu bousculé son
design à la fin de l'année 2017
en sortant à l'iphone disent justement
cet iphone et ce pourrait apporter
quelques nouveautés mais d'un autre côté
garder un look un peu en savoie il ya
deux écoles principale par rapport à ce
que pourrait être l'iphone et ceux de
2018 mais avant toute chose avant de
vous en parler davantage je vous pose
une question pour savoir ce que vous
souhaiteriez pour cet iphone et ce
est-ce que vous penser qu'apple va
sortir en 2018 nouvelle version de
l'iphone est ce et si oui qu'est ce que
vous aimeriez que cet iphone et ce est
dans le ventre
est-ce que voudriez qu'il a un design
plus comme l'iphone 10 est-ce que vous
souhaiteriez qu'il garde un design un
peu plus classiques comme ce qu'on a
retrouvé sur l'iphone 8 7 enfin tous les
modèles antérieurs
est ce que vous aimeriez qu'ils gardent
un petit écran un petit coup de pouce ou
alors avoir un plus grand écran d'un
drap mettez la pause marquée mais votre
commentaire j'attends et puis ensuite on
peut y aller donc anormalement c'est bon
vous l'avez marquer allez on continue
alors je vous explique pas ce que il ya
vraiment deux écoles différentes
il y en a une à laquelle j'adhère plus
l'autre à laquelle je crois - alors il
ya des rumeurs je vous en ai déjà parlé
dans une précédente vidéo qui d'ailleurs
ici je vous invite à aller voir
yamin tiko qui est l'analyste de kadji
sécurities qui a effectivement annoncé
selon lui qu' apple sortirait trois
nouveaux iphone cette année il
arrêterait la production de l'iphone 10
et ils sortiraient de nouveaux iphone 10
ou 10 évolution un de 5,8 pouces 1 avec
un plus grand écran qui serait aussi un
iphone 10 plus et un avec un grand écran
6,1 pouces mais par contre avec un écran
lcd
alors ça c'est je dirais la première
école de croire que de penser en tout
cas que ce que pourrait être cette
iphone 6,1 pouces avec un écran lcd
serait en réalité le futur iphone est ce
c'est à dire un design vraiment comme là
10 un grand écran une petite encoche sur
le haut par contre pas de recharge à
induction avec la caméra troude health &
faith heidi une seule caméra à l'arrière
pas de te tchaï dit forcément une
structure en aluminium une batterie un
peu plus anciennes pas les battrions
elle met les batteries rectangulaire
avec des capacités qui sont inférieurs 3
giga de ram
voilà un peu ce que dit cette rumeur
alors effectivement ça peut être très
intéressant parce que c'est vrai que si
apple sort un iphone et ceux de deuxième
génération avec le design de l'iphone os
x ça peut être super par contre moi j'y
crois pas du tout si on a effectivement
un très grand écran avec une encoche ça
veut dire qu'on a la caméra trou d'air
ce qui se trouve en haut du smartphone
l'acadien et rodez a mis du temps à
venir
de par les innovations de pas la
recherche développement appuie de par le
coût de la technologie tout simplement
parce que vous avez quand même une
projection infrarouges sans me le visage
il ya énormément de capteurs dont c'est
quelque chose qui coûte cher donc j'ai
du mal à croire que apple sur un produit
low cost un produit d'entrée de gamme
qui va se positionner vraiment en
dessous des 500 $ puisse inclure sa
dernière innovation directement dans ce
smartphone il a donc là effectivement je
n'adhère pas qu'on ait un design avec un
grand écran
pourquoi pas se rapprocher un peu du du
bord à bord ça peut effectivement se
tenir mais on est quand même loin de ce
que de ce qu'est en tout cas de
l'essence même de l'iphone est ce parce
que l'essence même de l'iphone ne faut
pas l'oublier c'est un petit écran c'est
un 4 pouces
c'est donc quelque chose de très compact
qu'on peut glisser facilement dans un
sac à main facilement dans une poche et
qui par rapport au format actuel où il
forma qui se développe énormément c'est
à dire ses smartphones beaucoup plus
grand si apple va changer et part sur ce
très grand format à mon avis ils vont à
l'encontre même de ce qu'est l'essence
même de l'iphone est ce je pense plutôt
que apple va garder le design l'aspect
de ce qu'est l'iphone et ce et de ce
qu'est son annonce de ce que sont en
tout cas ses anciennes générations
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut retrouver un
iphone et ceux qui se ressembleraient un
iphone 8 plus petit avec un écran de 4,2
pouces 4 5 pouces avec une résolution de
640 par 1130 pixels on serait sûr du
190 pays voilà quelque chose un petit
peu dans cette idée là
alors bien évidemment pas de oled du lcd
on gardait toujours le touch heidi un
produit qui aurait deux gigas de ram ou
3 giga de ram qui par contre pour un
processeur plus puissant
il serait doté du processeur à 10 fusion
qui est présent dans l'iphone cette une
batterie qui devrait être aux alentours
de 1700 milliards eur 1700 1800
peut-être 1901 stockage 32 ou 128 gia
est par contre je pense que l'action de
retrouver une recharge à induction et
qui vit une recharge à induction didot
anvers alors bien évidemment pas de
caméra trop d'aix le touch il dit une
caméra de sel fille qui serait améliorée
amélioré par rapport à l'ancienne
version de l'iphone est ce qu'on doit
retrouver cette fois ci une cette méga
pixels et au dos une seule caméra de 12
mégapixels c'est un produit qui pourrait
disponible en gris or et argent
on devrait voir un tarif autour des 419
euros parce qu'on est effectivement sur
une stratégie d'entrée de gamme de
capter ces consommateurs qui vont vers
des téléphones low cost alors low cost
sont des guillemets parce que 419 euros
malgré tout pour un téléphone nu ça
coûte de l'argent c'est quand même
malgré tout un budget mais par rapport
au marché de la téléphonie mobile
surtout chez apple 419 euros c'est
vraiment un produit d'entrée de gamme ça
produit qui pourraient être lancés ou
d'abominables ou dc en 2018 voire
peut-être avant alors moi avant ça me
surprendrait
à mon avis ils vont vraiment attendre le
d'abeilles ou d'abeille ou dc pour
l'annoncer pour mémoire du contenu parce
que de toute façon les iphone sur des
produits qui sont lancés en grande pompe
ses des produits qui sont attendus et
sur lequel il ya énormément
d'informations
l'idée du est ce serait conservé c'est à
dire un produit compact qu'on peut
garder pour le glisser dans une poche et
qu'on peut ranger extrêmement facilement
donc on va très bien qu'apple là-dessus
paraît effectivement aux amoureux des
petits produits aux amoureux d'apple
dayot s et qui veulent pas forcément
dépenser des fortunes pour avoir le
dernier flagship d'apple est ce un
produit qu'ils pourraient être assemblés
en inde par miss tron il ya plusieurs
sources qui font état de ces rumeurs je
n'ai pas inventé il ya effectivement kg
sécurities avec chico est aussi dj time
avec son analyste luc line pour beaucoup
parler aussi
il ya aussi l'economic daily
use de chine qui en a parlé à feindre la
donc énormément de source
j'ai cherché pour recouper les
informations qui me paraissait être les
plus pertinentes mais voilà donc on
ressent vraiment deux grands types de
produits qui pourrait venir pour cet
iphone et ce très grand écran qui sera
une espèce d'iphone dislike beaucoup
moins puissant soit cet iphone et ce qui
ressemblerait plus à un iphone 8
plus compact et qu'ils resteraient dans
l'essence même de ce qu'est en tout cas
cet iphone est ce donc voilà maintenant
qu'on a regardé la vidéo maintenant on
en a parlé
dites moi ce que vous en pensez par
rapport à ce qu'on a vu tout de suite
est-ce que ça confirme ce que vous
pensiez pas ce que vous imaginiez est-ce
que ça la foutait complètement est ce
qu'on est vraiment à l'opposé est-ce que
vous pensez que ce produit pourrait être
un produit intéressant puis surtout est
ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
séduire par cet iphone et ceux de 2010
vif
je vous invite bien évidemment à me
marquer tout ça en commentaire comme
d'habitude à me laisser des jo les
pousse à vous abonner parce qu'on va
parler toujours plus toujours mieux de
high tech
y'a pas un papa pas plein de choses à
venir j'ai une énorme surprise pour le
mois mois - pour le mois à venir
j'en dis pas plus restez connectés
abonnez-vous à très bientôt
merci d'être toujours là plus nombreux à
vous abonner à la chaîne vous êtes les
meilleurs
à bientôt merci vous embrasse ciao
[Musique]